so this is like the world's most
important freezer the most important
room in the world someone else's these
are pretty big claims for a place
located just 1,300 kilometers or 800
miles from the North Pole but then this
is no ordinary place
it's the Svalbard global Seed Vault well
actually this this is just its front
door inside the C vault are a series of
tunnels it's not actually that cold
right here but as we go deeper it is
only going to get colder this is Ben
thing you're an engineer Ben thing yes I
am you're gonna show us where to go yeah
fantastic how many doors are there five
doors to the secret room
whoa that's what I'm talkin about
they used to fit the lengths of tunnels
that take you down into the seat belt
this facility was built to last around
200 years and withstand earthquakes and
explosions it was placed on the side of
a mountain so even if all the ice on
earth melts it will still be above sea
level there are three separate vault
rooms where seeds are stored but only
one of them is in use right now and it's
buried over a hundred and twenty meters
from the front door the whole point of
putting the vault so deep in this
mountain is to put it within permafrost
so all around me the earth naturally
stays around minus 4 or minus 5 all
year-round and that way if something did
happen and the coolant stopped flowing
here there was no power then well behind
these doors it would still remain in
probably you know minus 4 minus 5
Celsius forever assuming of course
global temperatures don't rise that much
this place is sometimes called the
Doomsday vault because even in a
worst-case scenario it should preserve
the diversity of the world's food crops
really in the mountain surrounded by
permafrost
and here is a cross tunnel that leads to
three vault doors vault number one is up
there well number two and this is the
one that's actually being used and then
vault number three it's pretty amazing
to look up and see ice-covered ceilings
and walls everywhere the Svalbard global
seed vault works essentially like a bank
vault yes yeah because the theater play
in the Box does like this these boxes
are sealed when they come to us Walmart
and none of us are can open it where we
put it to this security system at the
airport just to check that it isn't any
explosives or or anything it is but it's
work it works like a bank box so we
could open this only the depositor can
open and take out their seeds so you
don't open any of the seeds any of the
boxes there's no well how you know that
people are really depositing the seeds
like barley that they say they are and
not other things just because they have
signed the contract that's is it we
could we can't be sure but of course we
trust them would there be seeds for some
crops that people might consider a licit
like marijuana that is said that that's
trouble shall not be in here no no drugs
and also no gene modified materials no
genetically modified seeds go in here
yeah are there any particularly strange
crops has anyone deposited anything
that's really odd or weird no nothing
really yeah it's in here but we have we
have we get some questions from people
wants to put in their own private seeds
I also have had had her had letters from
men wanting to put their gene material
in that is really strange and and we
don't answer those this is the door the
vault and behind here they're new
a million different varieties of seeds
from all over the world kept at minus 18
degrees Celsius you know how I can tell
that it's minus 18 degrees in here you
can actually feel the moisture in your
nose freeze so your nostrils get all
stiff yeah and I see behind you we have
some Canadian seeds which is exciting
for me because I am Canadian so what
sort of things do we have from Canada
I'm really not sure because this box on
the outside doesn't tell what is in it
but these are these numbers here are
connected to our database on the
internet so you can go in there
afterwards there you go yeah we go find
out you could find out what has Canada
got stored in the seed vault what are we
looking at right here yeah it's like a
bank vault except everything you've put
in there is publicly available it is
these are the coolest boxes I think they
are from North Korea oh my goodness you
have made boxes they look like they come
from the 1960s or something they built
them specially because they got the
measurements so how big should the Box
to speak and these are built exactly on
those measurements here you see a North
Korea is placed on the same shelves as
to you USA is just on the back there
it's on the back side and you have South
Korea just on the back so here they are
like in small United Nations deep in the
mountain so small market so these are
the last few bare shelves in vault two
once the other two vaults are full there
will be around three million different
species of plants stored here with over
500 seeds per sample so one day there
may be over a billion seeds stored
inside this mountain representing the
vast majority of Earth's agricultural
diversity and you don't know today what
kind
of our seeds that you can grow in 20 30
40 years from now because of the climate
change perhaps you have to use another
type of of seed 30 years from now that
can handle warmer climates drier climate
wetter climate it yeah it's going to
happen so that is why it's so important
to have a backup of all these seeds so
that you are sure that you can also grow
the food we need in for the next
generations to come but this isn't the
only seed bank on earth there are around
1700 other gene banks around the world
run by different countries and
organizations and at a cost of 9 million
dollars to build the Svalbard Seed Vault
and millions more to rent it's worth
asking whether this is a costly
redundancy or a valuable insurance
policy and perhaps the best people to
answer this question are the Syrians who
last year were the first to make a
withdrawal from the Seed Vault
the gene bank in Aleppo in Syria is now
out of order it's been bombed so one
third of the material that is kept in
here it's now taken down to Morocco and
Lebanon and this is some of the material
that now has been returned that's why
there's will those seeds actually be
used to grow crops what they will yeah
over the last thirteen thousand years we
have cultivated millions of species of
plants the agricultural revolution
underpinned the technological and
population explosions that made our
modern lives possible the risk of a real
doomsday scenario is incredibly remote
but whatever happens
thanks to this outpost at the top of the
world at least our seeds are safe
hey I'm currently on a train traveling
from Washington DC to New York City so I
can't talk too loud and actually after
Norway I went to Seoul South Korea Los
Angeles Boston New York and Washington
so it's been some crazy travels for me
and on all these travels I've been
listening to audiobooks from audible who
also support veritasium which I'm very
thankful for if you didn't know already
audible has like 250,000 titles in all
areas of literature including fiction
nonfiction and periodicals and if you go
to Auto audible.com slash veritasium you
can get a 30-day free trial of the
website where you can just try out
listening to a book so if you're at all
interested in listening to audiobooks I
highly recommend you check them out and
there's a book I can recommend to you it
is my favorite fiction book of all time
it's called everything is illuminated by
Jonathan Safran Foer it is I I don't
know it's just such a complex interwove
and novel you have to you have to read
it or listen to it to really know what I
mean but you can check it out you can
download that book for free for a
one-month trial or you can pick any
other book of your choosing so I really
want to thank audible for supporting me
and helping me go to all these amazing
places and I want to thank you for
watching